So you remember pastor
was very fond of, of, uh,
received making tartaric acid.
So when he'd travel around,
he would look for samples of
tartaric acid. They're very,
uh, detailed accounts that he
published to these travels.
I haven't found this one, so I'm not
sure it's true. It may be apocryphal,
but it was told me by the guy
who taught me organic chemistry.
So I pass it on to you for what it's
worth because it makes a good point.
He said that posture was in Alsace,
that wine producing region in northeast
France and in the town of Tom,
he found in a pharmacy a bottle of
receiving weak acid that was moldy.
So remember receiving
acids, the 50, 50 mixture.
So since he liked receive mic acid,
and in fact it was becoming rare.
It's not a very common product.
Mostly you get the handed stuff.
So we took it back and cleaned
it up, got rid of the, the, uh,
mold that was growing on it.
And what he found was that
after he had purified it,
it was the unnatural.
The left hand did not
the one you normally get.
Can you see an explanation for that?
Why did had the apothecary mislabeled it?
Because he thought he could get a higher
price for receiving me confer tartaric
acid or might have been innocent. Zack,
what? What would, what did the mold do?
Didn't convert the mold.
Eight.
The natural stuff converted it into
something completely different.
Leaving the unnatural one.
Okay.
Remember the smell of the
car owns natural things,
enzymes and so on can distinguish between
the two hands and naturally the stuff
that normally eats tartaric acid is
going to eat normal tartaric acid,
not the unusual ones.
So it left the unusual one.
The penicillium glaucoma had eaten the Rr.
Okay.
So that's one way of doing ras,
of doing resolution to get rid of wanting
antitumor from a receiving mixture,
leaving the other one.
Uh,
because Daya Steri Americ
reactions have different rates.
It's a right hand shaking or right
hand versus the right hand shaking the
lefthand. They're just different. So
one will go faster than the other.
So if you react Uracil Rasamayi
with some chiral reagent,
of course you have to use only one hand
of that other thing you add in there,
but then you'll react with
one more than the other.
It could be even a catalyst so that
it doesn't get consumed for an enzyme,
for example.
But that's not nature's way because it's
very inefficient to make both and then
destroy one. What nature does is
prepare only wanting a a tumor.
And you can do that.
Prepare only won by starting with
something that's already a single lien,
a Auntie Maria and building on that.
Or you can use a reagent which is
resolved that will that because Daya Steri
Americ rates are different.
We'll pretend to produce one, uh,
one of the two enantiomers.
So here's an example of this molecule
we've been talking about Asi seven, three,
eight, nine, with its 19
asymmetric centers that's made
artificially commercially.
Uh, and this is where
those 19 centers came from.
Five of them came from starting materials
that they bought as a single hand,
but the rest were all made.
One of them was done by chromatography.
They have chromatography columns about
this big around and this high with Cairo
stuff inside.
So you pass your thing through one hand
to goes through a little faster than the
other because it's Di Diet,
dietary Americ interaction with the
packing one comes through quicker and they
actually do that for one of the centers.
But the others are all done by reactions
that preferentially give one center
rather than the other three of them are
ones that everybody knew which one they
would give the other ones.
They just had to hope and and fiddle
around with different reactions until they
found one that would do the trick.
So anyhow,
they were able to generate
these 19 stereo centers.
Now we're left with a problem that that
incidentally is all we're going to have
for the exam on Friday.
Okay.
So now we're on to other stuff that
will be covered on the final exam and in
particular return to this
question about the tartaric acid.
Remember there's d plus and l minus
cause you have l plus and d minus
of a different compound.
Why not?
What does D or l mean in this context?
That's
Andrew.
It means which way it rotates the light.
Right?
And the plus means the same thing as d.
So it's redundant,
this particular nomenclature.
But there's a question mark because
when fee Fisher just guest remember,
and it could easily have been the
opposite. So which way is it? Right?
So if we knew,
if we knew how optical activity worked,
then by measuring the Abdel activity,
we'd know which of those
structures is right. Okay.
But we don't know that at least,
I don't know that.
Now there's a lot of knowledge about
this, but it's a very, very tough problem.
Fortunately.
Uh,
there's a book by Lawrence Baron called
molecular light scattering and optical
activity, which goes into this stuff.
And I see professor of a care, oh,
so we have a copy of the book.
That's great.
But even better than that,
we have Lawrence baron or a copy of,
or a coffee of Lawrence Baron. Perhaps
it's the mirror image of Lawrence Baron.
So he's going to tell us how this works.
So we've got the stuff on your
collar
and there is your clicker.
Okay,
well,
good morning everybody.
I was both from delighted and dismayed
at the same time when professor McBride
asked me to try and, uh, uh,
thinks well to address you this morning,
delighted to have the opportunity to talk
science to some of America's brightest
budding young scientists,
but also dismayed that he asked me to
try and explain the molecular origin of
optical rotation optical activity.
It's a very subtle,
difficult,
delicate problem that's exercise some
of the finest minds in physics and
chemistry for the last hundred years.
But anyway,
let's see how it goes towards the end.
I think I may be presenting some stuff
that's sort of beyond the boundaries of
your current knowledge,
but anyway,
it can at least pass
in front of your eyes.
So can I run a t then
beans as you well know,
right or left hand Ignis it pervades much
of modern science from the physics of
elementary particles through organic
stereochemistry to the structure and
behavior of the molecules of life with
a lot more besides that comes up in
what's called nonlinear optics
involving intense lasers,
nano technology materials, electrical
engineering, pharmaceuticals,
astrobiology and origin
of life. So it's, it's,
it's a very important
theme in modern science.
Now, first of all though, I'll, I'll
tell you a little bit about Lord Calvin.
He was the first person to introduce the
word [inaudible] Allity into science.
He was professor of natural
philosophy and Glasgow,
which is my home university, um,
through, um, most of his career.
He will all of his career. He was
one of the giants of physics of the,
of the 19th century.
Um,
he's best known for inventing the
absolute, uh, Kelvin temperature scale.
Now, he was originally, his
original name was William Thompson,
but then he became famous and became,
so William Thompson.
Then he became even more famous.
So they made him a lord.
And when you're made a law in the UK,
you choose your title from some
place that's dear to your heart,
may be your home area. He took his title
from the, the name of the river, Calvin,
which runs through the
university park in Glasgow.
So whenever you use the absolute
temperature scale now in the future,
you can picture this idyllic scene.
Anyway.
So he was the first to introduce
the word Chi reality into science.
And here's his definition,
which you'll be familiar with.
I call any geometrical figure or
group of points chiral and say,
but it has chi Rolla,
if it's image in the Plain Mirror,
ideally realized cannot be brought
into coincidence with itself.
That was in his Baltimore lectures.
So he's just emphasizing the non super
imposed the ability of the mirror image,
the team as of a or a molecule. But of
course the whole subject started uh,
earlier with the wonderful work
of Louie pastor who showed, um,
mirror image chiral molecule show
optical rotation of equal magnitude but
opposite sign,
which was an epoch making discovery.
So you've come across then this a the
fundamental manifestation of optical
activity,
which is natural optical rotation.
You put linearly polarized
light beam into a sample,
say sample of a nicer tropic
collection of chiral molecules,
like a sugar solution and it will come
out the other side with the plane of
polarization rotated through some angle.
And if you put it in the
mirror image version,
you'll get an equal but opposite
sense of optical rotation.
Now it's not to be confused with something
called magnetic optical rotation.
The faraday effect,
I've just mentioning this to you.
You've probably haven't come
across the faraday effect yet,
but you may do later on in your
studies or in your professional life.
So I'll mentioned the faraday effect.
Faraday discovered in 1846
that a chiral samples,
not, not no, no optical out, no
natural uptick in activity there.
If you apply a static magnetic
field parallel to the light beam,
that will induce an optical rotation.
And if you put in,
if you reverse the direction of the
magnetic field relative to the light beam,
you'll get an equal and opposite sense
of optical rotation. Um, you know,
it would even work say for a
sample of water, for instance,
any material we'll show a faraday effect.
But this has been a source of
much confusion. In fact, um, uh,
to scientists. Now, Lord
Kelvin was on the ball here.
He knew all about it. He's,
he made a statement here.
He said the magnetic rotation has neither
right handed or left handed quality.
That is to say no Kyron city.
It's got nothing to do with [inaudible].
This was perfectly understood by Faraday
and made clear in his writings there.
Even to the present day,
we frequently find the chiral rotation
of the magnetic rotation of the plane of
polarization
class together in a manner against which
Faraday's original description contains
ample warning. Well, Lord Kelvin
would be turning in his grave today,
a hundred years later because
you still see papers, um,
which involve the faraday
effect in some way or other.
And in the introduction they taught
grandly of inducing Chi reality with a
magnetic field that is
completely wrong. Um, just uh,
for the record, it probably, uh,
beyond your knowledge at the moment.
Chiral phenomenon like
natural optical rotation,
they're characterized by what's called
tiny even pseudo scale observables.
A pseudo scalar is a number that changes
sign under reflection or inversion.
We'll, we'll leave it at that. But so
that, that's for the record. But w well,
it turns out that the essential cemetery
characteristics of natural and magnetic
optical rotation a completely different
and you need different sorts of,
um, you know, quantum
molecular quantum states,
different characteristics to support them.
But we won't pursue that right now.
Back to natural optical rotation.
Um,
for now we bring in
circularly polarized light.
So in order to detect
molecular [inaudible],
you must have some sort
of chiral prob well,
what we're using here is right and
left circularly polarized light beans.
They are actually mirror image chiral
systems so they can be used as chiral
probes.
So here's a representation of a
right circularly polarized lightbeam.
Um, now you, you know,
that light is involves, um,
electromagnetic oscillations in space.
And usually you,
you just think of the oscillating
electric vector of a lightweight,
even if it's linearly polarized,
it's oscillating in, in one plane.
There's actually also an oscillating
magnetic field vector that's oscillates
perpendicular to the electric.
We'll come back to that later.
This is where just looking at the
oscillating electric vector here,
so if it's linearly polarized,
it's plain polarized.
It's just oscillating in a plane,
but circularly polarized light as well
as the oscillation in this direction.
You also have an electric factor
oscillating perpendicular,
but I'm 90 degrees out of phase,
and what happens is,
um,
you get this circular polarization.
Now this picture here,
this represents the instantaneous electric
vectors at different points in space,
in the direction of propagation
along the z direction.
And so here we are.
That's just a showing that just connected
the ends of the instantaneous electric
vectors. And there it is. The
left circularly polarized. Anyway,
you can see that at the very
least, those are, those are Chiral,
those are helix and those
appear image colonel systems.
Now Ah, here we go. This, this, this,
an extra sciencey stuff that
professor, but bride added to my, uh,
my presentation. He doesn't like
it was simple and static. Uh,
anyway, so there we are. So,
so now if you look at the wave,
if you just look at the electric
vector through in a fixed plane,
as the light wave is propagating,
there's the electric vector and
it will rotate in the fixed plane.
So rotating clockwise, that defines
right circularly polarized light.
And here we go.
Broke tasting counter clockwise.
That's left circularly polarized light.
Okay. So where we now have, um,
a chiral optical probe
circularly polarized light.
Now chiral molecules respond slightly
differently to right and left circularly
polarized light. Um, you know, and I mean,
an extreme example is say in the world
of, of engineering, you, you know,
you can't fit a lefthanded
not onto a right handed bolt.
That's an extreme example of
different, uh, you know, uh,
uh, chiral interactions. Well, it's
obviously a much more delicate than that.
Here point is right and left circularly
polarized light interact just slightly
differently with,
with a molecule of a given try reality.
Anyway,
there's a differential absorption of
right and left circularly polarized light
that corresponds to a phenomenon
called circular dichroic awesome,
which is the basis of a widely
used form of spectroscopy,
used to study a chiral molecules.
But now what gives rise
to optical rotation is a
difference in refractive index
towards, um, uh, of right and left
circularly polarized light beans.
Now linearly polarized light.
You can describe it as a coherent
superposition of right and left circularly
polarized waves of equal amplitude.
Coherent means they're in phase with
each other rather than being, you know,
random.
They're oscillating in phase with
some fixed phase relationship.
So, for example, now here's
a linearly polarized, um, um,
light beam,
but you can decompose it into a super
position of a left circular and the right
circular component.
You see it when those are at the top,
they're reinforcing and uh,
you've got the maximum linearly
polarized vector up here.
As they come away,
left and right,
they will tend to increasingly
cancel and that will decrease.
And when they're this way and
this way you'll have zero, um,
electric field back to there. And as
you come down, that will increase again.
So you, so you can, you
can decompose a lineage,
linearly polarized light into a coherent
superposition of, of left and right,
um, waves. Now,
refractive index corresponds
to a velocity through a medium.
Um,
so if there's a difference in refractive
index for right and left circularly
polarized light beams,
that means there's a slight difference
in the velocity of the right and left
circularly polarized light
beams going through the medium.
So the phase relation between the two
contra rotating electric factors will
change. And you can easily
see this will give you a,
a rotation in the plane of polarization.
You see if,
if there's a difference in velocity,
then it cements that this back to
will this electric vectors of the left
component will be here and
the right component here.
And if you take the results and
you see it's, it's, it's no longer,
um,
where it was.
So this is a simple picture of how
optical rotation develops in terms of,
um, different refractive indices of the
right or left components. Um, now there's,
um, there's a, a picture in
Atkins physical chemistry.
He tries to illustrate this there.
He's got the linearly polarized been
coming through and you've got the,
but he's broken it down
into the left and right.
And he's saying the two velocities are
slightly different and that gives you the
results. Optical rotation, um,
you can easily develop an expression for
the angle of rotation as a function of
the difference in refractive indices
for left and right circularly polarized
light beams. And it's also, it's
a function of the path length.
Obviously the longer the path
links, the, the, the more, uh,
rotation we'll develop.
And, um, it's, there's,
there's the wavelength there
in the denominator. In fact,
I mean this is the secret.
There's path length.
That's the secret of how you
get a measurable rotation.
Cause this is an incredibly tiny effect.
If it was just a single molecule event,
you're looking at the polarization
changes, you, you wouldn't see anything.
They're so tiny,
but you can build up this rotation
over long path link centimeters or even
meters. Um, in fact, um, if,
if you go to Google and Google images
and just Google circularly polarized
light,
you'll find lots of sites there which,
which described polarized light
and they provide beautiful, um,
simulations, animations of, of,
of this effect here.
I didn't want to download any
and try and show them here,
but I would encourage you to go to that.
But go and look in
particular at this site here,
ends in dot u that's comes from,
uh,
an institute of enzymology
and Buddha Pass.
They've got some beautiful simulations
of this optical rotation process and
another more exotic a polarization effects
as light propagates through latter.
Now let's try and, uh, so
that's, that's just, um, uh,
what would you say? A phenomenal
logical description. And in fact,
that's where most physical chemistry
textbooks stop. And in fact,
Atkins physical chemistry stops
at that point. And then just,
there's just sort of hand
waving saying, okay, you know,
right and left circularly polarized light
interacts like knee differently with
the chiral molecule and they leave it at
that and they don't attempt to try and
give you a picture and a molecular detail.
But a professor McBride wanted
me to try and attempt this.
So just as a, as a start, as
this is a simple, simple picture,
a simple scattering picture of,
of optical rotation.
Now a circularly polarized and lightwave
bouncing from one group to the other,
um, as it scatters from a simple
two group chiral structure,
we'll sample the Chi [inaudible].
So here we have a simple two
group chiral molecular structure.
So we've got to a chiral groups
held in a rigid twisted arrangement.
I think that's, that's lefthanded I've
got there. Um, and you can break down,
you look at most chiral molecules,
just look at the bonds.
You can often break them down. You can
see these sorts of two groups structures,
uh, um, throughout. Um, anyway,
uh,
so a [inaudible] model of optical rotation
is that the lightwave it bounces from
one group to the other before coming off
and getting involved in the generating
the optical rotation phenomenon.
Um, but you can see it's,
it's sampling the [inaudible] as it
bounces from one to the other. So if the,
if the light beam is right,
circularly polarized,
that bouncing process will have a
slightly different amplitude as we say,
from if it's left circularly polarized.
So that gives you a simple picture.
It's worth mentioning that this is the
basis of something called the dynamic
coupling model of optical activity that
was developed by somebody called John
Kirkwood, who was a chairman of
this department in the 1950s. Um,
well now we really have to
have to grasp the nettle at this point
because you just, it's hopeless
and messing around with these,
these simple models. They, they,
they don't get to anywhere as
regards prediction, you know, uh,
relating a structure to
sign and magnitude of,
of optical activity.
You have to go to the quantum mechanics.
So now this was the expression for
the optical rotation in terms of the
refractive index difference for less
than rights that can be polarized light.
Now you can develop this using something
called quantum mechanical perturbation
theory and you develop an expression
for the rotation angle in terms of this
incomprehensible looking stuff.
But let me just try and give
you a feel for what it, uh,
what it's telling us that the heart of
it is this so called rotational strength,
which involves the so scale,
a product of an electric dipole and
a magnetic dipole transition moment.
So what we've got here is there's
the ground state of the molecule.
N J is some excited electronic state
and mew is the electric dipole operator
that's connecting the
ground to the excited state.
And the lightwave is, is, is interacting,
is coupling with this electric dipole
operator and it's driving the transition.
And it's this, these electric
dipole transitions like this,
that's the behind
conventional spectroscopy.
You've done probably UV
and infrared spectroscopy,
but now what we have in addition is the
same transition but now brought about
through m,
that's called a magnetic dipole operator.
And that's activated by this oscillating
magnetic components of the light wave.
Um, and so you have this so
called scale of products that,
so myu dot m that would be mew,
x Mx plus mew,
y m y plus music. Then said, some
of you have probably done vectors,
maybe others haven't, but okay,
so that, that's the heart of it.
But this is a very important feature here.
We're summing over all excited states,
Jay,
all excited states.
So the whole plethora of excited
states of a car or molecule,
um,
come in here and some can can give you
one particular excited state can give you
a positive contribution to
the optical rotation. Another
one, a negative, you know,
so it's a very,
very subtle problem and um,
and you have to consider
them all carefully.
So optical activity ultimately originates
an interference between electric and
magnetic dipole transitions during
the light scattering process.
That's the sort of the heart of it.
Now, let me just show you how this
works out. I can now give you, uh, uh,
a chemical, uh, an
interpretation in terms of, um,
of a real and highly important
system in inorganic chemistry.
The carbonyl Chroma fall,
I believe you have come across the
carbon are Kromer for a lot of important
organic molecules contain
this Carbonell chromophores.
It gives rise to a transition in the
near ultraviolet at about 290 nanometers
and it's widely used in physical,
organic chemistry and,
um,
it's called the end to Pi star transition.
Now, the carbonyl group itself,
there it is. That's not chiral.
That's, that's got to play in
a cemetery. So it by itself,
it's not go, there's going to
be no optical activity there.
But you see in this
particular molecule here,
three Mikael cyclohexanone
fat molecule overall, his car,
or there's a chiral centered there.
So that carbonyl group is experiencing
a chiral perturbation or through space
perturbation from the rest
of the chiral molecule.
And that induces [inaudible] into the
electronic transitions of the carbonyl
group and in juices,
optical rotation and circular Dyke Rosen.
Well,
let's look at this in a bit more detail.
This a famous into to Pi star transition.
So here we've got the,
the sigma bonding or
of the carbonyl group.
There's the pie bonding
orbitals made up of two, uh, uh,
p Pi on carbon and oxygen.
And, uh, here is a loan here, sorry.
Here is a p y or before. So, so
those are, those are px or bottles.
That's, that's The p y or
buffalo on the oxygen feed,
electrons in.
And so you've got to the ground state,
you've got to there to there and you've
got two electrons in the pee while,
but also those are lone pair electrons,
so the lowest order,
but the lowest transition now is the,
the p y to Pi staff often called
the enterprise star transition.
You're promoting one electron from the
Pyr bottle up to the Pi star or Bethel.
And that's the, that's the
origin of, of this, uh,
transition. Well, let's,
uh, now, okay, now this transition,
it happens to be fully
back detic dipole aloud,
but completely electric dipole for bitten.
What happens.
This electric dipole character
is induced by mixing, well,
I'm giving the example of of a,
of a higher oxygen,
d y Zed orbital into the Pi
Star or buckle. Now professor,
but bride has been messing around with,
by presentation here.
Let's see what he's done. So here,
so here's the, here's
the, an orbital, uh, the,
the pee while battle
of the carbonyl group.
There's the Pi Star. Oh No, here we go.
So this is now and then,
but yeah,
so here you can see in that
enterprise star transition,
there's, there's a net rotation of, of
charge, a rotation of charge. And that's,
that's the essence of the
magnetic dipole allowed character,
magnetic dipole and transitions
involve a rotation of charge
for this change in the orientation.
That way,
right? So what's, ah,
okay, now here we go again.
Now here's a d y,
zed or Bethel.
Now one could consider a whole loads
of other possible orbitals to big sin.
But this is the simplest one to just
to illustrate the, the idea here.
So there's a d y,
zed orbital.
Now going from you c and Two d y Zed. You,
if you add those orbitals
together, the, that, the, uh,
you, you tend to get a
displacement of charge in the,
in the, um, in the zed direction.
So now you'll see you have a combination
of a rotation of charge with a
displacement of charge and
rotation plus translation.
Gibbs, he listened. He, and here we go.
Yeah. So by mixing in a
little bit of the, um,
this dx said orbital,
um,
you get this w which is electric
dipole allowed you get this, um, this,
he listed it in,
in the transition.
No, in fact, um, the,
the rotation of of charged generates a
magnetic dipole perpendicular to the,
to the, um, uh, plane of rotation
and it's pointing that way.
So you'll get a,
an mz said components or components of
the magnetic moment along the zed axis.
Here you can see immediately you've got
a component of the electric dipole along
the zed axis. So that generates
a music and zed component,
uh, from this scale, a
product of mew, and then in,
in the rotational strength.
So this is a sort of making
a meal of it here now.
So we're just putting down these so
called quantum mechanical matrix elements.
So here we've got end to Pi Star with
little bit of that mixed in and that's
fully magnetic dipole aloud.
Then we have end to Pi Star,
which is forbidden electric dipole.
But mixing that in gives you a
little bit of dipole character.
And so you now get a nonzero
contribution to the rotational strength.
However, you wouldn't want
to go, go on and, and,
and actually calculate the
optical rotation of the
carbon carbonyl chromophores
in some situation from
this because as I said,
there's many other excited electronic
states you could have also considered,
which may be giving opposite,
um,
contributions to the rotational strength.
You have to sum them all.
And to do that you now
have to go too modern, um,
ab initio quantum chemistry,
quantum chemical calculations.
There's wonderful programs out now
or from galcion and Delta and you can
calculate all sorts of molecular
properties with, with quite good,
a very good accuracy in,
in many cases.
But this now turns it all into,
into a black box procedure.
You just feed in appropriate
atomical befalls and press buttons.
And turn handles whatever you do for
these calculations and out we'll pop some,
um, physical quantity. So, so you
can calculate this, this whole thing,
ab initio and taking in a however
many excited states in the, in the,
some are necessary and you can,
you can calculate that the size and
magnitude of the optical rotation for a
given absolute configuration.
So you,
you would feed into the calculation
whether it's the s or the are absolute
stereochemistry.
So you'd put that in and that will
determine the sign of the optical rotation
that comes out. And so, um, I
mean in this particular case,
this small molecule,
the s absolute configuration goes with
the plus rotation and the Argos with the
minus. Um, so from the calculation,
then you can relate the sign of the
optical rotation to the absolute stereo
chemistry,
but you wouldn't want to stake your
life on it because it's not completely
reliable. You, it's usually gives the
right answer for smaller molecules,
but not always. And for
example, if, if this was,
um, uh, as, as you know,
and I think you'll hear
more after my talk here,
um,
many drugs now are our chiral
and come drug companies,
um, like to market now single
in TM aversions of the drug.
So it's a tremendously
important problem for them to,
to know with absolute certainty the
absolute configuration of the particular
enantiomer their marketing because they,
if they make a mistake and specify the
wrong absolute configuration in their
pattern, they can literally
lose billions of dollars. Um,
anyway, there's the, there's the famous,
the importance of, of Chi reality in,
in drugs is,
uh,
exemplified by the famous
thalidomide the case.
But I won't elaborate that anymore.
I think professor McBride is going to
tell you some more of that in more detail.
I should say that the,
the, the, the corner stone,
the definitive method for determining
absolute configuration has for some years
now been something called the by foot
method of anomalous x ray scattering,
which again, professor, have you
told them about that? Yeah, yeah.
That's the definitive method.
But it's sort of cheating
because you're actually seeing,
you're seeing it through
through ex-ray eyes. Um,
but even then they can,
you can occasionally make mistakes,
but I should just mention also there are
some newer optical activity techniques
involving something called vibration.
A lot to collectivity.
Here we've been looking at optical
activity in electronic transitions using
visible light,
but in recent years,
newer methods measuring up to connectivity
in vibrational transitions have come
along and these are actually comparable
with ex-ray anomalous x ray scattering
for reliability of absolute configuration.
That's because the,
these calculations are much more
reliable for this, these vibration,
a lot to collectivity phenomena
than electronic months. Well,
that's about it.
That's all I would like to say now.
So thank you for listening.
[inaudible]
okay.
Oh,
I'm just wondering if the magnitude of
the faraday rotation can ever interfere
with the measurement of optical rotation
that the material that is to say
there's one situation polarimeter
and proximity to an Nmr spectrometer,
for example.
Yeah,
no, I know you wouldn't need
to worry about that at all.
Now you might need a reasonable strength
of magnetic field just applied directly
through the phone.
Yeah,
Lucas.
It's just in my understanding,
uh,
the end of high star is,
men are dying all loud electric
deputy forbidding [inaudible] to lie.
Then it goes too deep,
uh,
at z as well in order to get in there.
That contribution.
Yes.
Uh,
okay. Thanks. Good luck.
Thank you.
So, uh, yeah,
this is just the plug,
this apple doing.
The reason professor Beran is here as
he's the Tuttleman lecture and Jonathan
Edwards College, so he's giving a
talk for the history majors and so on.
But it'll be very interesting for any,
why didn't,
I think since we're into Chi rally,
you would enjoy this particularly this
afternoon and Davies Auditorium at five
o'clock. But there's
the question, who cares?
No offense, but who cares? Why
do we care about ty rally? Well,
the professor Beran hinted at it. Living
thing is care because they're Tyrell,
right? So which one they react with. Okay.
The Food and Drug Administration cares
for the same reason with respect to
medications. You might be taking
drug companies care a lot.
And there are lawyers and the
u s patent office care a lot,
right? Which is generated the
thing called a chiral switch.
Most drugs that used to be developed
were developed as Rasamayi.
It's cause it was difficult
to separate the two hands.
But if your patent runs
out on the Rasamayi and you
can resolve it and now sell
just one of them,
and if it's better and the
FDA will approve it and you
can convince people that
that's the one they should buy,
then you can go back to not having to
compete with generic drug companies
anymore in charge.
$5 a pill instead of 50 cents a pill died.
So this so-called called chiral switch to
go from receiving mic to a single lane.
And humor is a big movement nowadays.
For example, consider this pain reliever.
Let's figure out what it is.
Do you remember what that group is?
Four carbons in that sort of Mercedes
structure. You know what that,
what that group's called this the this.
What we're doing for the rest of
the lecture here, however it is,
is actually review for the exam on Friday.
You're not specifically responsible for
it, but it's review. So we know that group
isobutyl.
Okay.
And what acid is that with three carbons?
Do you know
the first fatty acid?
Propionic acid.
And in the middle we have
fennel group.
Okay.
So what's the name of the drug?
Sherwin.
Ibuprofen.
Advil or
Motrin. Okay. Now in this case you
have a chiral center there, right?
Cause there's a hydrogen
on there that we don't see.
And the [inaudible] is the pain
reliever it said to be. So anyhow.
And the R is inactive. Right?
But it's marketed as Uracil mate.
Right.
One might try doing a chiral switch and
selling only the s but the trouble is
that it very quickly rast
summize is inside you.
So it wouldn't be doing any good.
Right?
Cause you'd do all the work of selling
the s and then it would become our
immediately when you eat it.
And here's another one.
This is the one that professor
Beran was referred to,
which is a sedative Felita MyEd.
And there's the chiral center in that
one because there's an h on there.
So the s form is a sedative, but the r
form, at least it said is to ride engine,
which means it makes monsters and it's
not so funny because it was sold as
Uracil mate from 1957 to 62 and never
in the u s because the FDA didn't,
they were lucky it never approved it.
But in Europe it caused 10,000 birth
defects. Children born without arms out,
legs, things like that.
So it was a tragedy. Uh,
but this one also undergoes in
Vivo Rassam causation. Okay.
These you can find rate
constants for these.
It's curious that the rate of ESCO into
our and the rate of are going to s are
not the same. It must, there must,
there's got to be more to it than that,
but one has to be more stable than
the other of these mirror images.
If that's true, it may be that the
rates aren't exactly true, but if so,
they must be bound to something that
makes chiral that makes one of the more
stable than the other. Anyhow, that's
how fast they go back and forth.
And this is how fast they
get eliminated from the body.
One gets eliminated much
faster than the other.
And if you put these things together,
you can see how the concentration should
vary with time if it's going according
to that rates.
So the blue one,
the one that's good for you
quickly drops off the bad one.
The Toronto region grows quickly,
so you have maybe two hours of 24 hours
where you've got a lot more of the good
ones and the bad one. So essentially
this drug is completely off limits,
especially for any women that could
conceivably under any circumstances be
pregnant. Okay. So, uh,
but it's a wonderful drug for things
like leprosy and so on. Uh, uh,
David here is a MD as well
as the professor of chemistry
and he'd probably know
more about that, but it's a wonderful
drug for certain things in that, right?
That's right. That's right. It's still
actually in common usage for anxiety.
But there are all sorts of warnings
and letters this big about if you're,
if you have a chance of getting pregnant,
stay away from this baby, right?
If you're a male patient taking it and
your wife is pregnant or likely to become
pregnant, you're encouraged
not to take it. Wow.
Wow. Okay, so now here's, here's a drug.
We're going to look up the name of this
one. It's a really cooperative a name,
right? So let's just use this as a
practice about nomenclature. Okay,
so that thing there is called amid all,
and the one h tells where,
which one has a hydrogen on it,
right? Okay. So that's the position
one. And that is the benzene ring.
So Ben, so it's bins of Midazolam. That
group on the right and you number it.
Remember it was one age,
there's an h on the nitrogen one there,
and you go around the ring a number
in that conventional way. Okay? Now,
but then you notice that
there's something on the,
on the number five and there's
something on the number two carbons,
have that ring on five.
There's a meth oxy group,
which appears first among all the
things in this [inaudible] named here,
not the thing that's on to why
is the methoxy group first,
do you remember what the rule is?
How do you arrange the substituent groups?
Angela Alphabetically?
Amazon's going to be the first one.
Okay.
So five methoxy and then two is so final
that s with an o audit is called soul
final group. Okay. So it's two, so final,
but now there are all sorts of curly
brackets in square brackets and so on to
tell what's attached to that. Okay.
So attached to that is uh, uh,
is methyl group, but the methyl is
substituted. So its methyl, so final.
Okay. That's the, that's the, uh,
currently the square brackets. Okay.
Now what's on the methyl,
there's a purity in group that benzene
with a nitrogen at this parody in and
it's substituted on the
methyl at its own to position.
The two position to the purity in is
what's attached to the methyl. So it's uh,
so it's two para dental,
the end,
but now on that in the four position is
methoxy and methoxy comes alphabetically
before methyl, not before d but before
methyl. And you don't count the die,
right? So there's the name of that
compound and this stuff is a drug.
It's a gastric proton pump inhibitor.
So it treats acid reflux disease and
it's the world's largest selling drug in
the year 2006 point $2 billion.
And it's called a MEP
Rizal or [inaudible] Sec.
And you've seen probably some of you at
least have seen boxes of [inaudible] sac.
I don't, you hope you don't have
to take it like I do occasionally.
This is called OTC. We're going to be
talking about that on Monday. Okay.
So there it is.
Now get your glasses up
because can you see this it,
can you see any sort of
three dimensions here?
What's in front or what's behind?
Can anybody tell?
Do you have any luck and see it in three
dimensions? Some people can't see it,
but most of you,
like 95% of you shouldn't be able to see.
It's not a really high quality
three dimensions and the,
because the computer,
the projector doesn't do it
exactly right for the colors.
So one IC is only wanted one sees
all of the other. Anybody see? Okay.
Now what is chiral here?
Can you see why this thing is chiral?
There's no carbon with four
different things on it,
but what makes it hand it?
Can you see?
In fact there's no group that
has four different things on it.
Any suggestions?
Uh,
Lucas sulfur sulfur has an unshared pair,
an oxygen and two different
art groups and which,
which is pointed out toward you.
Okay.
Can you see it enough in three dimensions
with the glasses to see that to see
which is pointing out Paris?
Yeah,
it's the unshared pair
that's pointing out.
So if you use your thumbs and not
recognize that the unshared pair has the
lowest atomic number, zero, right,
then you could do it and you'll find out
that that particular when drawn there
is the s e a n d A. Umer. Okay.
So it's normally a map resolve.
[inaudible] Prosecco,
OTC are the Rasamayi.
But this one that's drawn here is
the s isomer and it's called what
asset map? Rizal. That's
the name of it. Right?
And or Nexium. Right?
And it's the s isomer,
right?
So this is the product of one of these
chiral switches where for a long time the
stuff was marketed as harassing rate
and now they market it as a single
antitumor Nexium.
And we tried this one last time,
so we're not going to spend
time on it right now. Uh,
that's what the class looks
like when they're doing this.
It's fun for me to see you.
Okay.
But there are other ways of doing the
stereo view and you can use Paris,
a pair of periscopes like this, right?
And the way that works, of course,
the point is for each eye
to see a different image.
So if you want to try those
and look at this after class,
feel free or borrow them. A few
wish. Right? So, so what, uh,
what the eyes perceive as a super
position in the middle. It's like this.
There are two pictures, but, and
if you can do it with the glasses,
you can do it probably just
by looking at this picture.
If you have a little while, but we don't
have the little while now the right,
I will see that the left eye will see
that. And you see in the middle there,
see the something in the same position
but in slightly different projections.
So, so the image in the middle of the
three seems seems to be in three d.
Okay. Now, uh,
we don't have time to go [inaudible]
we're going to do a lot of a curved Arrow
staff about how reactions
happen in making a map resolve.
And then even more
interesting in the action of,
of map resolve that
stops the stomach acid.
But we'll have to wait until
after the exam for that. Okay.
Thanks again to professor Beran.
[inaudible].